si hay veces son vectores en el espacio
dados por y bueno aquí nos ponen quienes
hay quienes ve a es uno entre raíz de 5
por y menos 2 / raíz de 5 por jota esto
es lo que está diciendo y ves 2 entre la
raíz de 14 x y más 1 entre la raíz de 14
por jota más 3 entre la raíz de 14 por
acá y recordemos que hijo take a son los
vectores canónicos es decir y es el 100
jota es el 0 10 y acá es el 0 0 1 muy
bien entonces el valor de y nos dan esta
expresión nos piden calcular el valor de
esta expresión en donde tenemos dos a
más b punto a cruz b cruz a menos 2 b
entonces esto esto en principio se ve
bastante complicado y de hecho si
intentas hacer este producto cruz pues
va a ser muy difícil muy enredado y
seguramente puede que puede que hagas un
error sin querer porque es bastante
bastante engorroso así que lo que vamos
a usar es un truco
muy bueno en que es el desarrollo del
triple producto cruz o lo que es la
fórmula de lagrange y esencialmente hice
un video en donde demostraba la fórmula
y sobre todo para aquellas personas que
les gusta saber de dónde viene una
fórmula no no no sé ustedes pero yo soy
de esos que si ven una fórmula me da
mucha curiosidad de saber de dónde sale
así que por eso fue que hice el vídeo y
esencialmente lo que lo que nos dice el
desarrollo del triple producto de el
desarrollo del triple producto o lo que
es la fórmula de lagrange es que si
hacemos el producto cruz de a con de
cruce muy bien hace uno ve cruce y luego
hace el producto cruz con a en este
orden entonces es lo mismo que tomamos
ve y hacemos el producto punto de los
otros dos y los multiplicamos entonces
tenemos a punto c por b esto es un
número real y esto es un vector entonces
estamos multiplicando un real por un
vector menos aa punto b es decir tomamos
ahora c y hacemos el producto punto de
los otros
a punto b que multiplica hace muy bien
entonces esto es lo que nos dice la
fórmula de lagrange y por supuesto hacer
este producto punto es mucho más fácil
que hacer el producto cruz que el
producto cruz tenemos que hacer pues
esencialmente primero tenemos que ver
quién es esto y aquí es en donde podemos
utilizar la fórmula de lagrange ahora
bien si te das cuenta esto está de la
forma está al revés verdad nosotros
queremos vector cruz lo que hay en un
paréntesis así que vamos a intercambiar
el orden y sabemos que al intercambiar
el orden de un producto cruz se cambia
el signo entonces tenemos menos a menos
2 b cruz este vector que es a cruz ve
muy bien quizás debía utilizar otras
letras pero recordemos esencialmente
sólo te tienes que fijar en las
posiciones verdad porque aquí b es el
que juega el papel de a o más bien a
juega el papel de nuestra vez que
juegues el papel de éstas e iu a menos 2
b va a jugar el papel de ésta
ahora para quitar este - vamos a meterlo
a este paréntesis y tendremos entonces
2b - a verdad es menos a más 2 b cruz a
cruz b muy bien y ahora si utilizamos
con todo con todo el rigor la fórmula de
lagrange y tendremos entonces que sería
b que en este caso es este vector a muy
bien a que multiplique es multiplicado
por el producto punto de los otros
entonces tendremos 2b - a y esto punto b
que multiplica por supuesto a a vamos a
ponerlo aquí a muy bien y luego restamos
luego restamos nos tomamos el que está
en esta posición que en este caso es b y
hacemos el producto punto de los otros
entonces tendremos
2b - a punto
y esto esto vamos a dejarlo así esto
multiplica a b muy bien entonces ahora
lo que tenemos que hacer es ver qué pasa
con esto y podemos usar la propiedad
distributiva del producto punto que
esencialmente nos va a quedar 2 b punto
b - b punto a aquí sería 2a punto b
menos apuntó a entonces vamos a calcular
todos esos primero necesitamos calcular
apuntó a y apuntó a es la norma al
cuadrado es decir la suma de los
cuadrados de las coordenadas en esta
primera es uno entre raíz de cinco que
todo eso al cuadrado es un quinto más
menos 2 entre raíz de 5 al cuadrado es 4
entre 54 entre 5 y esto fue muy
agradable porque un quinto más cuatro
quintos es uno muy bien vamos a calcular
ahora b punto b
de punto b es igual y la misma idea
sumamos el cuadrado de las coordenadas
entonces tenemos dos entre raíz de 14 al
cuadrado serían 4 entre 14 más
+ 1 / raíz de 14 al cuadrado que es 1
entre 14 +
3 / raíz de 14 al cuadrado que es 9
entre 14 y que agradable porque si
sumamos todos nos da 14 arriba 9 y 1 son
10 y 4 son 14 entre 14 que es 1 también
ahora vamos a ver cuánto es apuntó b es
el único que nos falta apuntó b apuntó b
es igual a bueno tenemos que multiplicar
coordenada por coordenada verdad y
tenemos uno entre raíz de 5 por 2 entre
raíz de 14 esos es uno por 2 es 2 y raíz
de 5 por raíz de 14 son raíz de 5 por 14
que son 72 entre raíz de 70 y ahora
menos 12 entre raíz de 5 por 1 entre
raíz de 14 son menos dos entre raíz de
70 entonces hasta aquí va un cero y
luego tenemos cero acá que multiplica
tres entre raíz de 14 entonces 0 x
de raíz de 14-0 verdad entonces sumamos
un 0 y esto pues nos da 0 esto es
bastante bastante bastante bueno porque
nos va a simplificar todo muy bien
entonces regresemos al problema original
y aquí si utilizamos la propiedad
distributiva entonces vamos a tener 2 b
punto b2b punto b que es uno menos a
punto b a punto b y todo esto multiplica
a nuestro vector
a todo esto multiplica a nuestro vector
a y luego restamos restamos vamos a
restar 2 b punto a 2 b punto a o apuntó
que es lo mismo menos apuntó a apuntó a
y todo esto multiplica al vector b muy
bien entonces vamos a hacer rápidamente
esta cuenta porque b punto b es 1
entonces tendremos
aquí tendremos 2 - a punto de que es 0
entonces tendremos simplemente 2 que
multiplica
muy bien
bueno tendremos menos y aquí es 2 x 0 es
cero menos apuntó a pero apuntó a es 1
entonces tenemos menos 1 y con este
menos de aquí tendremos 1
b2b y esto es lo que resulta de este
producto cruz pero si nos damos cuenta
hay que hacer el producto punto con 2
además ve pero eso fue lo que obtuvimos
entonces tenemos que hacer 2 a más b
punto 2 a más b2b y entonces qué es lo
que vamos a hacer ya para calcular esto
pues simplemente usar la propiedad
distributiva muy bien usemos la
propiedad distributiva y tenemos 2 a por
dos o más bien sería 2.2 a serían cuatro
apuntó a
y luego dos a punto b eso nos da dos
a punto b
y no sé vamos a cambiar de color por
ejemplo azul y luego tenemos b punto 2 a
que es lo mismo que 2 a punto b y luego
b punto b vamos a sumar b punto b muy
bien y esto pues otra vez que en
términos de lo que ya habíamos calculado
esto se hace 0 esto también se hace 0 y
tenemos cuatro por apuntó a que es uno
entonces tenemos 4
de punto b que es 1 y nuestra respuesta
entonces hasta este momento es 5 y de
hecho pues hasta este momento y esa fue
exactamente la respuesta verdad después
o bueno al inicio parecía este problema
bastante complicado porque hay b tenían
expresiones que se veían bastante
bastante temerosas pero resulta que lo
que tienen ahí b es que su producto
punto es 0 eso es en términos
geométricos significa que que son
perpendiculares o que son ortogonales y
además apuntó a es 1 también ve punto b
eso no es decir su norma al cuadrado es
1 es decir también su norma verdad sin
sacarle cuadrado tiene que ser 1
entonces eso nos facilita muchísimo las
cuentas al simplificar lo utilizando la
fórmula de lagrange entonces este
resultado de esto que parecía muy
complicado simplemente será 5